david pavot et professeur à l'école de
gestion de l'université de sherbrooke
bonsoir d'avis bravo grosse semaine avec
les tarifs douaniers puis on va en
parler dans un instant le brésil la
chine aussi mais d'abord sur cette coop
25 à madrid
les etats-unis sont sortis de l'accord
de paris madame pelosi et sur place
pourquoi marqué le futur surnom pour
montrer que les démocrates ne pense
peut-être pas la même chose que trump
mais il n'en demeure pas moins que les
états unis comme vous l'avez dit sont
sortis de l'accord de paris donc ils ne
sont plus engagés dans les accords qui
vise à la réduction des émissions de ges
donc c'est simplement de la présence
politique on n'oublie pas non plus qu'à
une diplomate américaine envoyés par
l'administration tram mais c'est surtout
la cie et sur place tout à fait à madrid
mais la présence de pelosi ne changera
pas nécessairement la donne non on
n'attend rien des américains cette
semaine et les deux prochaines semaines
a comme médecin tout à fait bon alors
parlons de ces tarifs douaniers du
président entre sommes donc sur l'acier
l'aluminium de l'argentine et du brésil
ces deux pays avaient été exemptés au
départ pourquoi tout à coup imposer des
tarifs douaniers au brésil et à
l'argentine alors la rhétorique de
l'administration trump ici est celle
d'accuser l'argentine et le brésil
d'opérer des dévaluations compétitives
de leurs monnaies alors c'est un terme
un petit peu technique qui simplement
simplement l'administration trump
annonce que le brésil et l'argentine
font perdre de la valeur à leurs
monnaies sur le marché des changes au
marché international des monnaies et
l'objectif qui serait derrière tout cela
c'est de favoriser les exportations
d'acier et d'aluminium brésiliens et
argentins
est-ce que ça se prouve est ce que c'est
vrai ça alors est ce que c'est vrai que
ceci favorise les exportations
oui c'est nécessairement quand une manne
d'une monnaie perd de l'argent ça
favorise les exportations
maintenant est-ce qu'il ya réellement
des dévaluations compétitives qui sont
opérés par l'argent par l'argentine d'un
côté et le brésil on peut réellement se
questionner on peut se questionner sur
le fond le l'argentine est dans une
crise économique majeure depuis 20 mois
quant au brésil la plupart des
économistes même l'immense majorité des
économistes aujourd'hui disent que la
chute du real brésilien est davantage
due
un manque de confiance des marchés quant
à la capacité du gouvernement ball sur
la baule sonara à respecter ses
engagements de campagne que de réelles
que de réelles politiques monétaires
opérés par ses états regardons justement
l'évolution depuis cinq ans du peugeot
argentin et du real brésilien du peso
argentin en dollars américains vous
voyez donc à droite dans le bas du
tableau le recul dé la dernière année
donc baisse
il ya effectivement une baisse on le
voit bien ici mais des baisses on en
avait vu quand même depuis un certain
temps donc la baisse et quand même
prononcé depuis un certain temps mais ce
n'est pas nouveau non c'est pas nouveau
et surtout quand on se rend compte ici
que c'est extrêmement mineure par
rapport à ce qu'ils aient eu par le
passé et surtout ce qui est un petit peu
surprenant c'est que qui dit
dévaluations compétitives des actions du
gouvernement
donc ici argentin pour dévaluer sa
monnaie or on sait très bien que il ya
plein d'externalités il ya plein de
d'événements qui justifie la baisse du
peso argentin et notamment la crise
économique majeur connu par le pays
aujourd'hui
et quand on regarde le real brésilien
par rapport au dollar américain
on voit également un recul depuis
quelque temps mais c'était beaucoup plus
marquée encore une fois 2015-2016 que ça
peut l'être présentement oui tout à fait
c'est exactement le même phénomène où
finalement on a des monnaies qui sont
pas nécessairement stable vis-à-vis du
dollar américain
hélas ici on se rend compte que la
baisse elle et elle est mineure et là
encore il a aussi encore une fois aucun
on n'a aucun élément tangible qui permet
de faire porter une telle responsabilité
au gouvernement brésilien
et pourtant le président brésilien
bodjona raw se croyait un des principaux
alliés des etats unis
quel est l'impact de quel sera l'impact
de ces tarifs douaniers sur l'économie
mais aussi sur la relation entre les
deux pays
mais sur l'économie c'est toujours la
même chose c'est toujours le
consommateur américain qui va payer plus
cher ses produits alors effectivement ça
peut être un petit peu ralentir les
exportations du brésil et de l'argentine
vers les états unis
on sait que le brésil est le deuxième
fournisseur d'acier que l'argentine
c'est le cinquième fournisseur
d'aluminium donc ce sont quand même des
fournisseurs importants pour les
états-unis - que le canada évidemment
alors après l'amitié très molle sonar
haut c'est l'amitié des gens preuve peu
fréquentables des relations
internationales jean
vous dire oui mais après donald trump
son principal objectif lui c'est de
satisfaire sa base électorale
on le sait que les élections américaines
s'en viennent pour sa réélection
donc ici va chercher une mesure qu'il
est facile pour lui de justifier j'ai
regardé je surtaxe l'acier l'aluminium
et ça n'a pas vraiment de conséquences
sur lui entre guillemets si ce n'est
celle de satisfaire ses électeurs est ce
que ces tarifs douaniers sont légaux
c'est une grande question
alors est-ce qu'ils sont légaux du moins
peut on peut se demander on peut
s'interroger on peut s'interroger c'est
vraiment ici est ce qui est une base
juridique dans le droit qui permet aux
etats-unis d' adopter de tels tarifs au
regard des statuts du fonds monétaire
international ici l'on nous dit que la
dévaluation compétitive est interdite
donc a priori que s'il ya une volonté de
dévaluer sa monnaie l'argentine et le
brésil peuvent être finalement dans
l'illégalité
or on voit qu'il ya pas de volonté à
priori a pas de volonté de l'état
maintenant est-ce qu'on peut adopter des
tarifs lorsqu'on utilise la monnaie ou
alors ce qu'une monnaie peut être un
instrument pour favoriser le commerce
international
a priori la question est extrêmement
questionnable regard du droit de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
et on pourrait tout à fait s'attendre
dans les prochaines semaines parce que
l'argentine et le brésil saisissent le
saisisse le juge de l'om sait et on
verra ce qui va se passer avec la chine
cette semaine également la pression des
tarifs douaniers va peut-être nous
amener à une accord une première phase
dans cette fois non plus c'est une
grande question à la relation sino
américaine au début du mois novembre on
se rappelle on nous annonçait un accord
commercial sur une fin progressive des
tarifs douaniers sino américain à venir
les derniers jours ont plus mis un peu
du plomb dans les ailes à cet accord
pour plusieurs raisons d'un point de vue
commercial il n'y a pas d'accord entre
les américains et les chinois sur la
question du transfert de technologie on
sait que c'est un gros irritant pour les
américains d'ailleurs antérieure à
l'administration trump dans leurs
relations avec la chine
dès qu'une industrie américaine va
s'implanter en chine
elle doit céder une de ses parts
finalement un investisseur chinois et
finalement qui va pouvoir avoir un droit
de regard sur finalement les procédés
les brevets etc et donc qui dit
finalement transfert de technologie
quasiment automatique et cette question
là n'est pas réglé la deuxième question
c'est la question de hong kong qui
aujourd'hui centrale
les etats-unis ont adopté une loi sur la
démocratie et les droits de l'homme en
compte dans les derniers jours cette loi
a été qualifiée d' abomination par pékin
et cette loi vise en fait simplement à
donner points à ce que les états unis
s'accordent un droit de regard sur leurs
relations commerciales avec hong kong
si la démocratie n'est pas respectée on
sait qu'actuellement ce qui se passe à
hong kong est un gros irritant pour les
etats-unis et pour la démocratie
bon alors on suit ça de près d'avesnes
pavot merci merci